and the difference between the
successful comics and not a lot of the
times comes down to who's willing to put
in the work
what's goodie comics welcome to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i'm comedian joel byers after 10 years
in this game and over 300 interviews
with the top comics in the industry i'm
here to share with you
all the tips i had to learn the hard way
so you don't have to
so on the topic of making your jokes
personal
it all comes down to exploring your own
personal
life you can create lists and
brainstorming and journaling
around what are unique experiences that
have happened in my life what is my
unique point of view on certain topics
oh how am i funny in real life a great
way to bring in
personal material onto stage is to start
paying attention to how you're funny
off stage we've interviewed over 300
comics and
several of them have said that the way
that they have found their voice on
stage is by starting
to pay attention to how they're funny
off stage whether it's certain
ways they're delivering it's facial
expressions it's attitudes they're doing
and you can start to translate that on
to stage
but injecting emotion behind it is
really what
our monthly contest is all about that's
why every month
it is an emotional theme because it's
there to inspire you
to write from an emotional state because
that's
really what an audience connects with is
that
emotion behind what you're saying that's
how they resonate with you the most
beyond just your words
and when you start writing from emotion
that's when
audience members are going to come up
and start complimenting you on specific
jokes and not just saying oh you were
funny i mean we've all watched comics
for an hour
and be like oh they were funny i don't
remember anything they said though
and that's where the emotion comes in
the emotion is what makes you
memorable to an audience so it comes
from like
this month's theme is confident so what
are times
you've been confident also what are
times you haven't been confident
or what does confident mean to society
what does confident mean
to you personally and just start
exploring it from all those different
angles
and you just brainstorm a lot of
different ideas fill up a page or two
with just ideas
and then you maybe pick one two three
ideas that you can start to build upon
but part of joke writing is just getting
it out of your head
and on to the page and that's the work a
lot of people don't want to do
that they'll write for 10 minutes in
real and think oh i didn't think of
anything funny in 10 minutes
it's a process you know 1 out of 10 1
out of 20 ideas you'll actually end up
writing jokes about
and the difference between the
successful comics and not a lot of the
times comes down to who's willing to put
in the work
so if you want to be a professional
comedian
acting like it now will help you to get
there faster so putting in that work
being willing to
write when you don't feel like it being
willing to write 20 things and only
keeping one
it's all a process my friends i hope you
found that helpful
this clip you just watched is actually
from our q a we do in our
facebook group where we also do a daily
joke writing contest so if you want to
write more jokes and connect with more
comics
click the link in the description of
this video
and i'll see you there oh
y'all like that y'all like that y'all
like that
y'all like that yeah shawty